what we're going to do in this video is
see that if we have two different
triangles and we have two sets of
corresponding sides that have the same
length for example this blue side has
the same length as this blue side here
and this orange side has the same length
as this orange side here and the angle
that is formed between those sides so we
have two corresponding angles right over
here that they also have the equal
measure so we could think about we have
a side an angle a side a side an angle
and a side
if those have the same lengths or
measures then we can deduce that these
two triangles must be congruent by the
rigid motion definition of congruency or
the shorthand is if we have side angle
side in common and the angle is between
the two sides then the two triangles
will be congruent so to be able to prove
this in order to make this deduction we
just have to say that there's always a
rigid transformation if we have a side
angle side in common that will allow us
to map one triangle onto the other
because if there is a series of rigid
transformations that allow us to do it
then by the rigid transformation
definition the true triangles are
congruent
so the first thing that we could do is
we could reference back to where we saw
that if we have two segments that have
the same length like segment a b and
segment
d e if we have two segments with the
same length that they are congruent you
could always map one segment onto the
other with a series of rigid
transformations the way that we could do
that in this case is we could map point
b
onto point e
so this would be now i'll put b prime
right over here and if we just did a
transformation to do that so if we just
did it if we just translated like that
then side
whoops
then side
would that orange side would be
something like that but then we could do
another rigid transformation that
rotates about point e
or b prime that rotates that orange side
and the whole triangle with it onto d e
in which case once we do that second
rigid transformation point a will not
coincide with d or we could say a prime
is equal to d
but the question is where would c now
sit
well we can see the distance between a
and c in fact we can use our compass for
it the distance between a and c
is
right is just like that
and so since all these rigid
transformations preserve a distance we
know
that c prime the point that c gets
mapped to after those first two
transformations
c prime its distance is going to stay
the same from a prime so c prime is
going to be someplace
someplace along this curve
right over here
we also know that the rigid
transformations preserve angle measures
and so we also know that as we do the
mapping
the angle will be preserved so either
side ac will be mapped to
this side right over here and if that's
the case then f would be equal to c
prime and we would have found our rigid
transformation based on sas
and so therefore the two triangles would
be congruent but there's another
possibility that the angle gets
conserved but
side ac is mapped down here so there's
another possibility that side ac
due to our rigid transformations or
after our rigid our first series set of
rigid transformations
it looks something like this
so it looks
it looks something
like that
in which case c prime would be mapped
right over there
and in that case we can just do one more
rigid transformation we can just do a
reflection about
d e or a prime b prime to reflect point
c prime over that to get right over
there how do we know that c prime would
then be mapped to f
well this angle would be preserved due
to the rigid transformation so as we
flip it over as we do the reflection
over d e the angle would be preserved
and a prime c prime will then map to df
and then we'd be done we will we have to
show that there's always a series of
rigid transformations as long as you
meet this sas criteria that can map one
triangle onto the other and therefore
they are congruent